California sucks there I said it but
that's where all the famous people are
no no we're talking real life here it's
not all rich kids in pool houses and
Mischa Barton on lesbian coke vendors
from a government standpoint there's no
worse state in the Union but Cali is the
only place to be brah
I guess it is if you like record
spending through the roof business tax
is an outrageous cost of living and stop
singing Bret how did we get to that so
brother was too hard to say so we
shortened it to Rho and apparently that
was too hard so now it's only rough
pretty soon the English language will be
done down to nothing but guttural sounds
Kali is the only place for me mmm
hopeful no no it's not this is you stop
yeah you got you gotten this bad I don't
know what do you guys think of
California these days is it still the
fun in the Sun Lander is it on the way
out myself I wanted to learn more about
the state and was fortunate enough to
get a phone interviewing with the
governor himself this is me our
Schwarzenegger hi governor this is
steven crowder i'ma phoning in for the
interview good morning
oh good morning to you do you mind if I
just start off with a couple of
questions no problemo great okay well
first um how would you rate the current
state of affairs in California negative
all right so you wouldn't you would
acknowledge that there is in fact a
problem yes what do you think that
problem might be the crazy deficit
spending right okay
well I wanted to ask you about all that
firstly why did my dad receive an IOU
from the government for tax returns who
is your daddy and what that I don't I
don't I don't really see how that's
relevant here come on don't book to me
all right well then he is uh he's a
small business owner much like myself it
must be very proud of yourself right
okay
I do see here that most of the people
who weren't paid in cash from the
California government were members of
the public sector themselves whereas
private businesses who overpaid sort of
got the short end of the stick stop
whining
you really think that the people of
California who got IOUs instead of cash
that they had earned are just whining
yes right well in Arnold I completely
disagree with you on that one
Wow well there's a way to speak to a
concerned citizen
you know mr. quartz that mr.
Schwarzenegger your state is sixty eight
million dollars in debt which is the
worst of any state in the Union and it
would take over over eighty four years
to pay off the debt assuming that you
stopped spending right now all right
what's so funny talk to the hand
what's the matter I just I just told you
what was the matter okay the cost of
doing business in your state is 20%
higher than your neighbors and your
out-of-control spending has led to the
near bankruptcy of California is how it
Brookes money comes in favors go out the
people lose I know that but you said
that you were Republican and that you
fight against this I lied oh this is
frustrating I feel like I've got a tumor
in my head and now that I know it's not
a tumor Arnold that was an analogy and I
know stop whining
what do you want to be honest at this
point I would just like a nap and some
cookies okay I'm told it you can eat my
cookies are not your cookies I bought
the cookies with my aunt that cook it
down no okay I've heard enough here
Arnold let's make it hurt enough today
clearly California has no more room for
the out-of-control spending but I don't
believe in a pump on this because I'm
good to a material comic oh geez